el teorema fundamental del álgebra
problema
fundamental
pregunta mental
de el álgebra
álgebra
qué nos dice el teorema fundamental del
álgebra pues nos dice que si tenemos una
función px
pd x dada por un polinomio de grado n o
sea algo que se ve de la forma a por x a
la n más b por x a la n 1 + c por x a la
enee menos dos y así hasta algún término
independiente
digamos que si tengo algo que se ve de
esta forma entonces necesariamente voy a
tener n raíces en este polinomio n
raíces o dicho de otro modo voy a tener
n valores de x n valores para x tales
que el polinomio evaluado en esos
valores me dé el número 0 y bueno quizás
ustedes estén recordando por ejemplo
polinomios de grado 2 polinomios de
grado 2 que tienen gráficas que se ven
algo así
algo así que tengo mi eje y mx y no se
podría hacer una parábola una parábola
que se ve algo así
y entonces dicen bueno ok esto es el
segundo grado del segundo grado
segundo grado
y efectivamente corta el eje x en dos
lugares tiene dos raíces
tiene estos dos países dos países
y quizás también se estén acordando de
polinomios de grado 3
vamos allá está en el eje x y vamos a
poner mi eje por aquí
x y mi polinomio de grado 3 se ve algo
así
y continúa hacia allá y efectivamente
aquí tengo una raíz dos raíces tres
raíces así que tiene tres raíces e
incluso podrían pensar en un polinomio
de grado 4 que se ve algo así
algo así
y entonces aquí tengo una raíz dos
raíces tres raíces cuatro raíces así que
suena bastante convincente el teorema
fundamental del álgebra pero pero de
repente ustedes recuerdan y dicen hoy en
un segundo también hay parábolas que no
cortan el eje x hay para volar como esta
que no lo cortan y esto es un polinomio
del segundo grado
de el segundo grado así que dónde están
mis dos raíces dónde están las dos
raíces que debería tener este polinomio
pues la clave está en que el teorema
fundamental del álgebra requiere que
expandamos nuestro sistema numérico ya
no sólo vamos a trabajar con números
reales sino también con números
complejos y de hecho el teorema
fundamental del álgebra también nos
permite que los coeficientes del
polinomio sean números complejos y nos
dice que siempre que tengamos un
polinomio de grado n va a tener en es
raíces complejas no necesariamente
reales en este caso por ejemplo las
raíces son números reales y los números
reales son complejos así que aquí tengo
mis dos raíces para este polinomio de
grado 2 aquí tengo mis tres raíces y
para el polinomio grado 3
y aquí tengo mis cuatro raíces para el
polinomio de grado 4 y en cambio este
polinomio de segundo grado que no tiene
raíces reales pues resulta que va a
tener dos raíces complejas dos raíces
complejas
complejas porque tiene que tener dos
raíces así que si no tienes raíces
reales sus raíces van a tener que ser
complejas y por ejemplo también
podríamos tener el caso de un polinomio
de grado 3 cuya gráfica se vea algo así
y entonces tiene una raíz real
solo una raíz real pero como es el
tercer grado como es el tercer grado que
pasa pues tiene que tener otras dos
raíces complejas y esa es la clave
siempre que tengo un polinomio que tiene
coeficientes reales las raíces complejas
van a venir en parejas de números
conjugados así que por ejemplo podría
tener un un polinomio de grado 3 del
tercer grado con tres raíces
no reales
reales complejas
esto es una situación válida para un
polinomio grado 3 existe es el polinomio
pues no porque como vamos a ver en
vídeos posteriores las raíces complejas
siempre vienen en pares de números
complejos conjugados si mis coeficientes
son reales
entonces también por ejemplo podría
pensar en un polinomio de grado 4 que no
tuviera raíces reales y que se viera
algo así su gráfica pero no hay ningún
problema porque puedo pensar que son dos
parejas de números complejos conjugados
ya veremos esto más adelante en los
vídeos siguientes